okay so I everyone welcome to the panel
about bias and fairness in the eye and I
will introduce you our panelists
so the first panelist is team Nita boo
she's a research scientist and technical
college of the athenian AI team at
google
she just finished a postdoc at Microsoft
Research New York City in the faith
furnace transparency accountability and
ethics in AI group where she studied
algorithmic bias and the ethical
application underlying any data mining
project our second panelist is Margaret
Mitchell she is a senior research
scientist and leads the Attic AI team
within Google research research is
interdisciplinary combining computer
vision natural language processing
statical Stickle methods deep learning
and cognitive science and she applies a
walk-in clinic analysis assistive
domains and our last panelist is
Brittney Sanders she is Deputy
Commissioner for strategic initiative at
the New York Commission of Human Rights
had the Commission Britney Minaj key
interagency partnership and special
projects related to data-driven
discrimination on racial justice among
users and before joining the Commission
Britney worked for the office of the
mayor most recently as Acting consent to
the Maya so now that we properly
introduced our speakers I will start
with some question and then you could
come and ask your questions to the
panelists
so first AI as an increasingly important
role in human affairs some professions
increasingly use it to assist in the
decision-making or even let it take
decision on its own how do we define
fairness and bias knowing the answer of
this question might determine how some
industries or interesting institution
will operate in the future
I'm sorry I have to turn it on
keep it open okay I'll keep talking and
then it turns on okay
I don't know how to use technology but
so I will let them answer the hard
questions and I'll say that I don't know
how to define fairness personally but I
I know what we see unfairness sometimes
and I think that's what's easier to
define and I think I've heard even Meg
say that if we ground it in human rights
and if we ground it in other types of
legalities that because the legal system
sometimes has defined these things for
us then we might get to a better
definition so I'll let you guys talk
about it but the one thing I want to say
is that I think especially meg and I one
of our sticking points is when people
want to work abstractly unfairness or
bias without either interacting with the
communities that are supposed you know
that are being unfairly you know but
that are being negatively impacted by
these algorithms or they're like write
papers and you know you have like in
your motivation you're you know you
could be like oh gender bias is bad or
you know african-americans yeah they
deal with XY and Z and you've never
worked with an african-american or a
woman you've never collaborated with
them or you've never talked to someone
like yesterday a black in the eye we
brought Terrence in who was unfairly
treated he was the the victim of these
alka crime recidivism risk assessment
scores right and most people who work on
this kind of stuff they have never
interacted with someone like him so of
what I would say is that when we think
about bias and fairness like this we
shouldn't think about it in the abstract
definitional sense but we should make
sure to work with the communities
are dealing with these things and make
sure that their voices are lifted their
voices are also on the papers and on the
you know fame and glory and not just you
know our careers being built on that
kind of misery and now you could we have
my house and we're lousy with
microphones here is this coming through
okay okay cool
so yeah there's a I think a lot of
definitions of fairness and bias in how
we use the words colloquially in
conversation and there's a lot of
definitions of fairness and bias in sort
of statistical domains and there is
oftentimes a disconnect between the
conversation and colloquial usage of
these terms and some of the more
mathematical and statistical usages of
these terms I know that we're talking
about bias and fairness sort of within
the machine learning context which
largely draws from and is inspired by
the colloquial usages but can be
somewhat detached from it and at times
even sort of defined in such a way that
it might further propagate issues of
bias and unfairness so to give you an
example a lot of a lot of machine
learning definitions of fairness focus
on things like parody so getting you
know equal error rates or whatever sort
of evaluation metric is relevant across
different subgroups whereas when we talk
about fairness generally sort of in
colloquial usage we're thinking about
things more like justice we're thinking
about things more like rights and there
can be a disconnect there in what we're
defining mathematically and actually
historically fairness has had other
surges other kinds of bubbles in
statistical worlds and died out in part
because it sort of got detached from how
words like fairness were being used
legally and colloquially
oh and I have a paper on this also okay
as - Shiro Mitchell who's also in the
audience but but I try a bridge bridge
the gap as much as I can and so when I'm
talking about bias and fairness and
machine learning I'm talking about
stereotyping I'm talking about prejudice
I'm talking about racism I'm talking
about sexism and that means everything
from who is asking the questions who's
starting to develop the technology to
the datasets that are collected to the
machine learning models to the outcomes
it's the whole end-to-end system that is
a part of this I think in machine
learning we tend to get really excited
about machine learning models and then
so like lose ourselves in how we can
define fairness and bias in the context
of machine learning models but there's
so much to do at the level of data and
there's so much to do at the level of
who's even working on this and so also
to to Nate's point like it's a little
bit frustrating to see like work on
fairness and inclusion that's largely
like majority demographic groups working
together and you're like you're missing
the larger picture because all of your
choices are now informed by shared life
experiences missing critical knowledge
diverse perspectives critical knowledge
that you don't have from people who are
less represented in your domain so
that's a long way of saying there are
lots of definitions and part of I think
what all of us are interested in doing
is making sure that the usage of
fairness and bias terms in statistics
and in machine learning is very closely
tied to what people mean colloquially
when they say those things please read
the history of fairness and by Ben
Hutchinson and Meg Mitchell I think this
is one of the most important papers that
I have seen in our community so it's out
this year she's really bad at
publicizing her work so that's I think
all that is great and I second a lot of
what I'm both Tim Eaton Meg said so I
would say that from so a little bit of
background the New York City Commission
on Human Rights is a local government
agency in New York City that enforces
our anti-discrimination law and so I
think from that perspective - Tim needs
point like looking at making sure that
we're grounded and connected to the
legal concepts that are relevant you
know in that context we think about
discrimination as different differential
treatment based on one's membership in a
protected category our law is very broad
so we have something like 24 different
categories of protection across our
three different areas of jurisdiction or
three major areas of jurisdiction which
are housing employment and public
accommodations and then we also have
jurisdiction over something called
discriminatory harassment which is like
harassment you might expand I'm
targeting for violence and intimidation
in public spaces and then also we have
jurisdiction over something called bias
based profiling by law enforcement so in
that sense it is this disparate treat or
differential treatment based on your
membership in a protected class and that
might be kind of direct or it might be
indirect because you know a particular
group of people is more likely to be
impacted by a policy or practice that
appears to be neutral but before I came
to the Commission and came to local
government I worked in racial justice
advocacy at a couple different
organizations and so I'd like to place
that kind of anti-discrimination
framework and the broader framework of
kind of structural and equity and you
know paying attention to the lake earth
long histories of racism and sexism
ableism and all the things that are
needed now to make sure that folks get
justice and to make sure that people can
thrive moving forward so it's it's kind
of all nested in one space but I
absolutely second a lot of what was said
in addition so for example let's say
this conference right now all the visa
issues we've been having have been on
the news right so imagine if like a
particular group of people were
organizing and let's say this workshop a
first social group good or a fairness
and bias and fairness workshop there was
absolutely no Africans involved people
would have no idea the kind of hurdles
that everybody else had to go through to
come here and the fact that they can't
even come here so what does it mean to
have a conversation about bias and
fairness when the people who are
experiencing hurdles are not even at the
table right so this is why it's super
important white what meg said we have to
think of it as an end-to-end system it's
not just the math and whatever it's also
it has to start from the very beginning
so now that we kind of define fairness
so as we know there is bias in the way a
software analyzes the world and you can
suss results in serious consequence for
people even if the technology is a is a
at an early stage and so my question is
what are some of the bias at putting
back people in this way in the next few
years and in the next few decades could
give some thinking pretty maybe Minister
um sure
I mean I think some of the things that
we think about that actually initially
drew our interest at the Commission to
issues of algorithmic bias were really
around one realizing that that AI was
increasingly being used in the
decision-making that we had you know
traditionally been looking at and those
three major areas of decision-making and
then also thinking about like well what
if we know that that these models are
trained using data then we ought to be
curious about what the sources of those
data are and what sorts of biases might
be baked in so for you know the human
rights law has basically evolved to
address different forms of
discrimination as they manifest and so
that means that I think we
we're kind of naturally curious about
how the kind of long history of
discrimination is reflected in the data
that that folks are using and then I
guess replicated through the models that
develop out of that and then also I
think there's some more kind of
nitty-gritty specific questions that
that we would have around like you know
what do we know not just about what do
we know about certain types of data that
might function as proxies for for or
certain types data might that might
include categories then [ __ ] shows
proper proxies for our protected
categories what do we know about sort
and certain like data sources right that
may frankly have low quality data be
prone to mistakes and then you know what
are the impacts of those for real people
that yeah I a lot of all those points
the idea around data and then that
biases in the data further getting
propagated through the system and then
at times even amplified its its use it's
useful to point out that that also
causes a feedback loop so the kinds of
information you get is biased in a
certain way and then you select among
that information and then that sends a
signal back that is used as data that is
retrained so this is like a pretty
problematic cycle once you start seeing
it which is I think why people that are
traditionally computer scientists are
more and more turning towards fairness
and bias because once your systems start
working and you start to see how they
work there's a lot of oh crap maybe I
don't want to continue developing this
you know and and the feedback loop
problem especially is is really
problematic and the fact that a lot of
the technology right now is being
developed by like you know economically
very well developed countries a lot of
people who are you know computer
scientist at top tech companies like
also come from sort of privileged
backgrounds and so that is causing a
kind of myopia in what gets developed
and what gets launched that then is
spread throughout the world
I think to me well maybe also hopefully
say this point about the homogeneous
effect of this but I just also want to
say that I think it's talking about AI
as a full system a full end-to-end
system
I think another massive bias right now
is the launch the pressure to launch
there's this idea of just like launching
is always good and part of why that is
true is because that's how you're
evaluated in tech companies like how
many launches have you made it's that's
what's incentivized and so I think one
of the most challenging biases that I'm
already seeing effects of we're already
seeing effects of now that hopefully
won't like continue that much but
probably will it's just this idea that
any technology is cool to develop and
you should develop it and you should
release it and here I'm talking about
face detection here I'm talking about
I'm here I'm talking about gender
prediction right like it's really hard
to work inside a corporation and say
okay we might have a system that can do
really well at this based on our data
set and also we should not release it
and that's a massive you're fighting
against a huge cultural bias at that
point you're also fighting against like
capitalism and so I think that that is
this underlying bias like we have to
release stuff things have to go out that
is a really really difficult challenge
right now so maybe I'll give some
examples of the bias that the biases
that have had real-world impacts so so
one example is hiring and so a lot of
you know there's all there's all these
different companies popping up so the
issue is that there are all of these
different companies doing all sorts of
things that we just sort of just find
out about every week or so right so
there's no no like FDA or whatever
approval process you know they're at the
Food and Drug Administration at least
like if we are going to develop a drug
or something you have to go through some
sort of approval process but if you have
algorithms that are
to decide some aspect of your life you
don't go through any sort of approval
process we have absolutely no idea what
you know what the model looks like what
your training data is we don't have
standards etc so a few examples for
these are there are these hiring
companies man I got contacted by the PR
people from hirevue because I keep on
giving them as an example but I will
give them an example again so the thing
is so a higher view is not the only one
but it's what's one of these largest
companies that they have over 600
customers so over 600 large companies
ranging from Nike to like all sorts of
tech companies some of the largest are
Procter & Gamble I think is one of them
600 companies multinational
international companies right so higher
views selling point is that so they they
do a clean and so what they do is one
things they do is that you know imagine
as a company you have thousands and
thousands of resumes coming in and you
don't want to hire like you know have
lots of recruiters going through these
resumes of them one by one to figure out
who to have in an interview etc right so
what they do is they have this automated
tool to screen out people based on their
resumes or other applications we don't
know anything about the characteristics
of this tool they're not required to
tell us what what it does are we just we
just they just offer it to all these
different companies it might as well
they do claim that like but after using
their tools that some companies came you
know had more diverse work groups of
people but that might be true that might
not be true we have no idea
and then so so they have this tool and
then once you interview okay like you're
you're having an interview they have
this tool where they record you in the
interview and then when they're
advertising it they say from the
recording people get verbal and
nonverbal cues about you so it's like
okay I'm getting interviewed and now
there's like something and then I found
out like I didn't even know how they
were due
and another panel with Rana that they
were using Affectiva to do emotional
recognition so I'm sitting in an
interview now with this emotion
recognition thing on me I don't know how
well that emotion recognition thing
works what if he thinks that Britney is
always mad like you know even if she
it's it's so we have absolutely no idea
what what what the characteristics of
these tools are and now and I know
people who went through this whole
hirevue process who didn't even have any
idea that emotion recognition was being
done on them as they're interviewing and
so they didn't and so like imagine we
have a few of these capitalism right
like a few of these companies like with
massive reaches making lots of money and
imagine if higher views being used not
just in the US but UPN like you know all
over the world and now you have like
this single failure point and if there
is some characteristic that I have that
you know people don't like or there's
something going on I could get rejected
from all jobs everywhere right so I
think these are the day to day kind of
things that that we have to watch out
for so so to some extent we can say that
bias in AI can reflect the programming
that
I need and also the data that are used
to to design it and it can even
reinforce previously existing human bias
for this and granted legitimacy so what
could we do to change the way a software
is designed to prevent this bias from
taking over on having unintended
consequences and in what way could a I
potentially change cultural mindset
either constructively or negative I mean
one thought perhaps selfishly from my
end is that I think it would like
there's a lot that we I'd say the
Commission don't necessarily understand
about how these are developed even it
with respect to the very specific
question of the degree to which folks
are researching or understanding or
exploring like human rights laws and
civil rights laws particularly as
they're developing these so I think a
maybe a greater openness to that sort of
conversation and a little bit of that
transparency it would be really helpful
and I think to echo a point that's come
up in a lot of the conversations I've
been a part of this weekend and
certainly in yesterday's keynote by
Terrence and the the following panel was
to Tim needs point right making sure
that you're not developing in a vacuum
and that you have an opportunity to hear
from folks who have been impacted or who
and may not you know like folks who have
interacted with the systems that you're
designing the tool for and who can tell
you like you know this is not like some
fresh landscape with you know with no
history like let me tell you about what
I experienced and other folks can talk
about some of the like the broader
landscape of what the experience has
been with those systems to give a little
context
yeah that's that's a really great point
and I kind of want to build on that as
well to say like I think there's there's
sort of a focus in people who develop
machine learning technology on like what
the user will think and it's not only
the users who are affected and so for
example if you're developing like facial
recognition software then companies that
are using facial recognition are your
users and that's how you're kind of
optimizing but facial recognition is
something that can be deployed on anyone
without consent and it's the form of
biometric identification so it's
massively it'sit's there's a potential
for a lot of negative harm not just at
the user level but beyond to really
anyone so opening up the conversation
about AI development and and who you're
developing it for to realize that it's
not just the users it's it can be
literally anyone that can be impacted
and and in light of that bringing
everyone possible to the table like this
goes to what we were saying before about
like some specific things that we can do
like support black and a I support Latin
XNA I you know like support groups that
are traditionally underrepresented in
technology to come and be part not only
of the discussion but of the development
we bring that critical knowledge to the
table and a lot of unintended
consequences won't happen because there
will be a lot of additional foresight on
how things might play out and sort of to
that point I think incentivizing
different kinds of important issues well
it will also really help mitigate some
sort of biases and unintended
consequences and so for example like I
hear a lot about hindsight and like
learning experiences I don't see a lot
of incentive ascent of evasion
incentivization of people who work with
a lot of foresight and make decisions
based on what their foresight is one of
the frustrating things about working in
fairness and bias is that you know
you've succeeded if there's not a
headline and that's really hard to
measure
and so somehow like recognizing people
who are making decisions with a lot of
thought into how this connects to
society how this connects to to civil
law and human rights and things like
that and how things might play out over
time avoiding disasters before they even
begin not even going down the path that
leads to those disasters and somehow
incentivizing that is really important
that can be done by giving awards for
best evaluation for example giving
awards for most interdisciplinary
research papers or diverse author lists
or you know there are so many ways we
can incentivize these kinds of things
and it's just not being done at all but
I think it would have a huge effect yeah
well we're think a lot of times you know
we're both involved in the conference on
fairness accountability and transparency
in social technical systems and the
machine learning community right now is
extremely focused on fairness fairness
part of that of the fairness Academy
transparency because it's it's you know
like so giving the example of the
compass dataset right so in 2016
república came up with this article
talking about the fact that there was an
algorithm be developed by Northpoint a
startup that was being used by judges
and and judges were like so the North
Point is a vendor and so judges were
using it as one of a certain number of
factors to determine you know someone's
likelihood of committing a crime again
and so this can be used to post bail
your bail amount can be like that you
know tens of thousands of dollars etc
etc so anyway so this article came out
and people in the fairness community
you're like oh yeah and then so the what
ProPublica article was saying was that
that this algorithm was biased against
black people and so then there was like
this is you know discussion debate about
whether or not it was
and what does it mean to be biased and
there was all this math and you know
math is fun that's why I you know that's
why I'm in this field that's why you're
in this field but and then what started
happening which is why we had Terrence
yesterday and Christian also wanted to
have Terrence is that okay now we have
the cup people develop the compass data
set okay and so now they have the
compass data set so they have abstracted
everything to a data set you don't have
to deal with like any of the structure
of problems or the people involved so
now that like they now you have the
compass data set and then we have paper
after paper being like okay when we have
this type of fairness record like
regularization added to like your
classification problem then we reduce on
you know this metric by this percentage
on this data set so the conversation now
gets back to that kind of that line of
thinking and so now you started having
these people getting abstracted more and
more away from the real problem and they
have never interacted with people like
Terrence who are actually the victims of
this kind of unfairness that the cut you
know the compas data says supposed to
investigate and so when when you're
doing that what happens is that you know
you might you might do some cool math
but you might be going after the
entirely wrong problem like you might
not be you know great you did X percent
you know you you got experts that better
but you haven't talked to people like
Britney you have to you haven't talked
to people like Terrence so they might
you when you talk to them they might be
like actually we can't even implement
this or this is not going to work right
so I mean this is why it's super
important to have this interdisciplinary
nature that meg was talking about your
point about headlines that's interesting
because I think that yes it's sure that
when you don't have headlines is when
you're when you're more when you're
successful but unfortunately sometimes
we have seen that it is when there are
headlines that the companies act it's
super hard to to do like well you're
you're usually going against the current
when you're trying to do this kind of
work in a corporation like she said
we're we're you know it's about the
money
like you know Kyra's just fired their
CEO who said that he does not want to
use face recognition for law enforcement
they've the board they fired him from a
company that he started himself because
they wanted to go the surveillance route
because that makes you more money and he
said you know he's a black man and he
was like I'm seeing how this is being
used against my community I don't want
to start a company a face-recognition
company for this to be used against my
community and he got fired from his own
company because that was not the way to
make the most amount of money so how can
we counter that the way we can counter
that is the negative person that comes
when you have this kind of products that
are released so that's what I've seen
like for example my work Joe and I had
had this paper we were trying to
convince everybody that things were
important and then whatever it wasn't a
big priority and all of a sudden it's
all over the news and everybody's like
we need to fix this what's going on we
have to end them within a month or two
people came up like with you know api's
that were better and stuff like that
because they have the they have the
resources so so I guess to answer to
your question is I wouldn't overly focus
on I mean there's things we can do with
the model there's a lot of work on the
on these a lot of people kind of have
add some retro lights or to the loss
that you know has some notion of
fairness there's things we can do with
the data which is like having more
representative data and stuff like that
but what meg and I both have been
focusing a lot more recently because
we've been hearing from people like
Britney is is give more information
about your model about your dataset to
different people using it like
policymakers like you know if I am a
start-up at developer and I have your
API or your are a publicly released data
set I want to know if this data set is
appropriate like face recognition I want
to know as the law enforcement should
this be used for
surveillance is it gonna unfairly target
like if it makes like terrible mistakes
you know to me if it mistakes like true
black people to each other it doesn't
have that kind of issue for other races
this is encoding discrimination even if
you didn't want to write but if you had
this information in some sort of
documented form then I could make a
decision be like oh I don't want to use
that so that's why we're working at
things like data sheets and model cards
to give more documentation you know I
was just gonna say Antony has a paper
called data sheets for data sets that
goes exactly into how to be transparent
about about these data sets in a way
that people sort of know what they're
using and we also collaborated on people
paper called model cards for model
reporting see how they're cute they go
together that does the same kind of
thing for model and that goes that's not
fairness that's no transparency and
transparency as a mechanism for
accountability and for people to be able
to pursue justice if necessary and also
for you know general customers to sort
of know what they're getting and compare
and things like that so yeah I think I'm
kind of babbling but I just I just
completely agree and transparency is a
really important part of this we
wouldn't have written this got these
kinds of papers if we weren't
communicating with people like you right
like so she Britney was talking she was
like transparency is the most important
thing right and with transparency we're
not it's kind of even different from
interpretability yeah yes yeah well
there's post hoc interpretability which
can be used yeah for you what are the
timelines involved in the search for
favor yeah
when do you think it will be fair
and is it achievable do you think it's a
ship ever are you Steven so your
question is do we when do we think it's
gonna be fair and is it ever gonna
happen is that kind of a question okay
well I think we can make AI more diverse
and inclusive and so I'd like to make
some a bit of a distinction between
fairness and inclusion where in fairness
a lot of times we're talking about
different kind of error rates and things
like that
and getting some sort of equality
between them whereas in inclusion we're
talking about increasing the
capabilities for a lot of different
options that would not be considered
offhand by people developing it so to
give a very concrete example of what I
mean by this
as I started at Microsoft Research where
I worked before Google they were just
completing the cocoa dataset and they
were making the decisions of what to
include in the cocoa dataset and they
had things that would be used you know
by everyone like baseball and baseball
bat and baseball glove and base and and
baseball hat and they threw away things
that weren't that comment like necklace
and I was just thinking like you got you
guys see what you guys see what you do
but it really wasn't part of the
conversation right because you just kind
of get into this groupthink myopia and
so I think that that what will happen is
more inclusion and more diversity we're
going to open up capabilities to include
the thoughts and considerations and
priorities of people who have
traditionally been underrepresented and
like we're entombed neat in particular
is single-handedly changing the face of
AI to make that so it's in a really
amazing way and so I I hope that this is
what we see more of so I think that that
is achievable and it's starting to be
more and more achieved I think that
there is always other ways to define
fairness and so I don't think well I
will say we will never get to a position
where most people agree this is fair
there are lots of types of fairness and
we can get to places where lots of
people agree on specific aspects of what
is unfair also to your point that you
made earlier and when we go to panels
and stuff we largely just agree with one
another so this is kind of void oh yeah
but I so I think that we can get to to
technology that is more diverse and
inclusive I don't think we will ever get
to a point where everyone says this is
fair technology I mean I I would just
say I'm this piece is that you know I
think the source of anxiety for a lot of
people is very much tied to what meg
said about the pressure to launch is
that you know obviously people are not
waiting to deploy these technologies
until we're certain that they're fair so
there's this there's this real pressure
to figure out how to deal with that and
one of the ways it's manifests itself in
New York is that in 2018 the City
Council passed a bill that established a
task force on automated decision systems
and so the task force is now looking at
some of these questions at least as far
as government application of the
technologies yeah I I just can't imagine
getting into a world where we're saying
AI is fair like we also have to get to a
world where we say the world is fair
like when is that gonna happen I don't
know I can't imagine that happening um
like I think we can make it more fair or
less biased we commit it so that's why
we always talk about mitigating bias
right we don't like the term unbiased
because a lot of people say we went to
unbiased this we want to unbiased that
or ordi bias you know the I think the
reason we came here in the first place
we got to this point is because we're
abstracting things too much
you know we've moved to a place where we
have a data set of numbers in this and
then we launch either a paper or a
product and what we need to understand
is the complexity of everything and so
if we just say hey you have now tested
this fairness metric that tournament
metric that fairness metric on this data
set is ready to launch it's D bias
I don't think that's a good way to go
about it either it's just kind of giving
more documents you know you can try to
unmitigated bias but also try to give
more documentation about which areas you
also think it's going to still be biased
and kind of have this conversation I
just I can't imagine getting into a
world where anything is fair sorry I
mean I don't need to be you know
pessimistic but the world is complex and
so there's one group or another who's
always going to be discriminated against
or something and then I buy you know
even car it's like okay you mentioned
data sheets for data sets like we had
car you know we talked about other
industries where these kinds of issues
happened right like so in cars and
automobiles and when people were testing
out on mobiles they only tested them on
dummies with prototypical adult male
characteristics and so then you find
that accidents were disproportionately
affecting women and children okay so
like then maybe you fix that problem
like right now with speech recognition
we even have groups of people you
wouldn't say that maybe societally they
might not even be discriminated against
but in our data set like we might not
have we might not train with a lot of
data set of kids for example so you can
create things that are now
discriminating against children even if
your society is not really necessarily
discriminating against children right so
it's very complex and so I think we can
just try to address different pieces of
it but I don't think we can say in five
years we'll get to a point where you
know or X number of years where it's you
know no fair thank you so I have a lot
of question that I will need yeah
huskers German question so if you wants
to go there's a mic over there yes so if
you want to ask a question go to the
microphone working yeah okay so I mean
Brittany and I have talked in the past
about kind of structural sort of things
in housing discrimination and so forth
gentrification and the conversation so
far has been all focused on kind of
algorithmic decision making the
allocations and so forth but what we
haven't talked about or what our way is
machine learning and artificial
intelligence can actually help societal
issues and so maybe you guys can comment
on that a little bit sure so I have
folks who were in the session as part of
in black and a high yesterday will have
heard this already but it might be
helpful or instructive to other folks so
one of like an example of how we've
tried to at least at the city level kind
of like technologies in a positive way
is that one of the categories of
protection under the City human rights
law is lawful source of income meaning
that you cannot be discriminated against
in the housing market because you use a
founder to pay for your housing and and
yet we still see a lot of it across the
city and one of the projects that we did
was we worked with our partners at the
mayor's office for data analytics who
are also represented here and you know
developed a model to help us predict
areas in the city where there were large
numbers of vacant units and where those
units were relatively affordable and
where they were in neighborhoods
that you know because of you know how
schools were ranked or whatever it might
be would be attractive to folks and so
we then identify those neighborhoods and
that became a way for the Commission to
look and to see okay well maybe we need
to focus some more of our testing
resources here maybe these are places
where we need to do more outreach and
education and talk to people and see if
they've been experiencing source of
income discrimination so that's kind of
one way in which I think it can be
helpful examples like for example you
can use machine learning to uncover bias
right like there is work showing that
performance reviews have gender biases
and so that's that's one way there's
work showing that Oakland police speak
less respectfully to black people when
they stop them and that's the you know
an NLP and that's a huge collaboration
with people in NLP and stuff like that
so there's there's a lot of work doing
this and and I even have hope that maybe
you know things like the hiring
practices could even help us uncover
biases just it's just that you know
we're all like machine learning like but
it's just that it needs to be done in a
framework where it allows us to have
checks and balances I'll just quickly
say also assistive technology on and on
a rude actually presented earlier yes
thank you very much for a great panel my
name is Luke stark I'm a post-market
here at Microsoft Montreal and I say
that because I work everyday with
engineers and researchers in AI and I am
absolutely 100% with you on the need for
a greater diversity and inclusion in the
tech sector in AI research but I I want
to ask a sort of more conceptual
question about about work in tech and
the kind of evidence that people in tech
need to not develop a system because we
can talk we talk a lot about social
reasons and plus the philosophical
reasons to not develop systems but I
think sometimes there's a sense that oh
we can well we can fix all those
problems with if we come up with the
right tentacles
so I wonder what you all think about how
to how to talk about evidence and how to
present evidence that convinces
technologists yeah I want to speak to
this because I'm working on this like
very directly um so one thing that does
help is activism to to to meets point
earlier you know market pressures are
oftentimes gonna be different than then
what activists can achieve and so if you
can drive a very clear narrative around
right and wrong like joyful and windy
does an amazing job at this that at end
drive headlines - two minutes point
earlier that can make huge changes and
and another thing to think about is just
being very clear about the pros and cons
of things um companies more and more
like Microsoft and Google probably some
of the other big tech companies are
thinking about benefits and risks in
terms of in terms of ethics in part
because this is a thing that is sort of
popular now and so it's a great time to
get in information about risks and
benefits around things that could
possibly controversial or problematic so
for example gender detection good or bad
like companies will not have a very
clear idea about this necessarily and to
the extent that people generally can
articulate the the risks the benefits
make that clearer how it might be used
that's something that companies will be
very responsive to at least now because
they'd like to know you know they want
to also know where their market
opportunities are so so just being very
clear about different kinds of risks and
benefits and activism as well as super
super important
sorry about that I am much shorter um I
was wondering what are the different
ways that you all have thought about to
help us continue to pursue or prevents
our companies to continue to pursue or
pursue a ifx because a lot of times you
know we do see how it's sometimes
reactionary against like any negative
headlines I think a lot of our companies
have figured out like diversity
inclusion is good for different things
but what are ways that we can like show
the more I don't know what and financial
incentives on the bottom line those
types of things just sort of like
translate this into numbers basically
like honestly it's really hard I mean
even diversity and inclusion like a name
yes everybody talks about it all the
time there's not money in sessions it
practice nothing changes nothing changes
you know it's just so hard to change a
culture and so you know what we what we
try to do is like build coalitions I
think that I mean really because just to
show that there are a whole bunch of
people who Meredith Whitaker is amazing
your address at Google so the whole meet
anti-maidan activists have happened
because of meredith whitaker so like
there's a whole coalition of people who
are who are against something so that's
one thing I figured out that helps but
in terms of even diversity and inclusion
there's all of these all of this
research showing that it's better for
business
better four boards and whatever and now
everybody has figured out that they
should say that they like diversity and
inclusion that's what happened they've
all figured out that they should say
that but in practice things are not
changing actually you look at the
numbers you know women leave at higher
rates and all this stuff and when you
look at the culture you understand why
but it's really hard to change the
culture unfortunately the majority does
not seem to understand why I'm worried
that now people have similarly figured
out that they should say they care about
ethics but then when it comes down to it
it's all of these things are going
against the grain you're fighting
against the current of what has happened
forever right
and so these individual head like so
gender detection now so Meg worked
really hard on trying to figure out why
not and I'll stop so you'd like really
good documentation and then building
coalitions but unfortunately I I don't
have better ear better thing to say no I
don't I definitely don't have the answer
on that one I'm just aggressively taking
notes here it's exhausting it's just it
feels like you're always fighting yeah
and no one says good job don't want your
issues don't launch that thing you are
super excited about for four months you
know and then like you are doing
something wrong like this is what you're
saying all the time is super exhausting
because I also want to be the popular
person so we we are running out of time
so maybe you can ask your question
back-to-back and then they can try to
answer yeah sounds good so my question
is about a secret sauce of AI I mean any
company has to really hold their trade
secret
prevent competition right that's the
enemy and do you feel like there should
be regulation against this for the sake
of fairness or what regulation would you
like to see so I think that I was so in
philosophy of science recently people
distinguish between two kinds of
diversity epistemic diversity and
demographic diversity and I think this
kind of distinction sometimes really
help us to say what do we mean exactly
by diversity especially when we want to
devise some strategies like in practice
and I was wondering if in tech industry
also you think that drawing this kind of
distinction more fine-grain distinction
is necessary or whether you have this
distinction already questioned as
follows on from your question actually
there's a there was a memo that the RAND
Corporation put out in the 60s when
they're trying to figure out how to hire
programmers and they said that there was
a gift and a curse of hiring programmers
because the best ones many would do what
they were told but very few would not do
what they were told and so they had this
great wealth of labor but labor that
wouldn't always think creatively in the
way that they really needed to make
serious progress and I wonder if if you
have what you would make of that
characterization if that remains the
case is that was a long time ago and
simultaneously whether you know in
medicine we have doctors and nurses and
the doctor you know as a tradition we'll
try and you know push research forward
and the nurses will help conform what we
know to what you want you may know what
to keep living do you think we're
actually missing a whole labor category
here a professional class of people that
help conform these kind of large-scale
autonomous systems to hyperlocal ethical
needs of different places
yeah I'll say very quickly that I think
on that last question I think there I
mean I don't know the extent to which
this is a thing that industry is
thinking about but like bringing some of
this expertise in-house in a bigger kind
of deeper investment way it definitely
seems
yeah so I guess my quick response to all
three questions is that that I think
that there needs to be bridging work
between engineers and other other kinds
of agencies and so like regulators and
so it's not so good to regulate
necessarily if you don't know how the
machine learning works because then you
might do something that actually works
against what your overall goal is on the
other hand like you might be doing
something as an engineer that you really
shouldn't be doing and so bridging work
to help translate know what the
questions are on both sides
what regulators might ask of engineers
and what engineers might ask of
regulators helping drive that
conversation would be really useful I
guess now I would just went back to
answering mostly the first question
because I really liked it but it's also
really good I think like a lot of people
are trying to say when you were saying
like you don't have divers time for
diversity but then we said look we have
wide type of diversity it's all it's
usually a way to deflect things so
that's the way I've seen it happen you
know it's like well you don't have any
demographic deficit but we have
intellectual diversity
you always hear this kind of stuff and I
think personally it's used to it's been
used to deflect things as my opinion on
your question about people being told
what to do I feel like the education
system the CS educational system is
partly what brought us here and I really
like paper the moral character
cryptographic work is like this paper
that I would really recommend everybody
reads because Phillip Brockway is a is a
professor and he wrote he said that the
failure to prevent mass surveillance is
really it falls on the cryptographic
community because they've just
abstracted out everything like any sort
of social understanding or whatever from
the work it's like
Alice and Bob are trying to communicate
and there's some adversary well who's
Alice who's Bob who's the adversary that
means everything and so it's a like a 47
page paper and I think we need some that
kind of paper for machine learning and
he talks about how nuclear physicists
were you know physicists were really
active in nuclear disarmament and all
this stuff and and he also talks about
how when computer scientists were being
asked and why they're choosing different
companies to go to nobody really thought
about morality and things like that a
lot of them are like well whether money
you know things like this and so we have
this concept where well my job is this
as an engineer partly because it's much
easier maybe I'm more fun to just think
about your your job in this particular
model or developing this thing and you
don't think about you know well I might
what is my responsibility in the overall
company or in the overall institution
that I'm working with and what they're
developing because that's I think that's
much more difficult and more complex and
not necessarily fun actually that's not
why we got into this field
right I didn't get into this field to
start black in the eye at like I just I
said I wanted to be a scientist when I
was little I that was not what I had in
mind so these are these are not the
reasons we get into these fields but but
I agree that even our educational system
it rewards us for doing exactly what
we're told to do you go to a class
you're told this homework you do this
homework in this exact specific way and
that's the only way you're going to get
an A so we haven't really been taught
how to not do what we're not you know
told to do so thank you very much to our
suite panelists let's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good thanks thank you thank you